Avengers...
"...assemble."
Fans can watch Earth's Mightiest Heroes aim
for the head, get rescued from space, learn
how to time travel, overcome all odds, and
bid final farewells to some of their crew
in a whole new way very soon.
Marvel Entertainment has confirmed that Avengers:
Endgame is coming to the soon-to-debut streaming
platform Disney+.
Fans who are keen to relive the epic highs,
crushing lows, and Cheez Whiz-filled middling
points of Joe and Anthony Russo's Infinity
Saga-closing epic can do so at the launch
of Disney+.
That's right: there won't be any waiting around
to stream Avengers: Endgame for the 12th or
1,200th time - you can load up the flick on
Disney+ as soon as it goes live in the U.S.
on Tuesday, November 12.
Marvel fans in Canada and the Netherlands
can also stream Endgame that same day.
Those in Australia and New Zealand will have
to wait a week for Disney+ to roll out, though
Endgame will be available to watch at launch
in their countries on Tuesday, November 19.
Sucks for you guys, huh?
"I'm kidding!"
Though Marvel Entertainment mentioned only
those five countries when announcing Avengers:
Endgame's impending arrival on Disney+, it's
likely that the film will be an at-launch
title for the vast majority of - if not all
- territories.
It seems a safe bet that whenever Disney+
launches, regardless of where in the world
you live, you can sit down for a lovely three-hour
Endgame watch session.
Don't forget popcorn and candy to nervously
munch on when tensions run high, and a box
of tissues to turn to when Endgame hits its
many emotional beats.
Touted as the go-to place for, quote, "never-before-seen
new movies, TV shows, documentaries, and more
from the world's greatest storytellers" with
"endless entertainment" and "streaming for
everyone," Disney+ is bound to become a massive
contender in the ongoing streaming wars.
What's helping position the streamer as such
isn't just that it's owned by Disney and will
feature hundreds upon hundreds of beloved
movies and TV shows when it arrives - it's
also because Disney+ will be the exclusive
streaming home for a number of new original
Marvel series.
The first Marvel superhero series headed to
Disney+ is The Falcon and the Winter Soldier,
a team-up show starring Marvel Cinematic Universe
favorites Anthony Mackie and Sebastian Stan
as their respective characters Sam Wilson
- a.k.a. Falcon - and Bucky Barnes, a.k.a.
the Winter Soldier.
Also featuring Daniel Brühl as the infamous
Captain America: Civil War villain Helmut
Zemo , Emily VanCamp as ex-S.H.I.E.L.D.
agent Sharon Carter, and Wyatt Russell as
John Walker, a.k.a. U.S. Agent, The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier is slated to premiere
on Disney+ sometime in the fall of 2020.
In early 2021, WandaVision, starring Elizabeth
Olsen's Scarlet Witch and Paul Bettany's Vision,
and Loki, the mini-series all about Tom Hiddleston's
titular trickster god, will arrive on Disney+.
WandaVision, which will also feature Teyonah
Parris as Monica Rambeau, has been described
as a weird series that's unlike anything Marvel
has done before - while Loki is being talked
about as a time-hopping collection of adventures
that sees Thor's adopted brother influencing
huge events in human history.
That same year, fans will feast their eyes
upon the animated Marvel series What If...?
which features a voice cast filled with MCU
mainstays.
They'll also get to dig into Hawkeye, which
sees Jeremy Renner's hero training a new vigilante
to take on the Hawkeye mantle.
But that's not all.
Marvel Studios, which oversees all Disney+
Marvel shows, has three more superhero series
in development set to debut on the streaming
service.
There's Ms. Marvel, centered around the Pakistani
American hero Kamala Khan; Moon Knight, focused
on the shadowy vigilante otherwise known as
Marc Spector; and She-Hulk, the series dedicated
to Bruce Banner's big, green, not-quite-as-mean
cousin Jennifer Walters.
Those three series don't have release dates
just yet, but Marvel Entertainment Chief Creative
Officer Kevin Feige has said that each and
every one of the Marvel-Disney+ series are
extremely important to watch if you plan to
keep up with the film side of the MCU.
He told Bloomberg in November 2019 that fans
will probably need a Disney+ subscription
to, quote, "understand everything in future
Marvel movies," as events that take place
on the upcoming series will connect to films
yet to come in Phase 4 - like Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness, which is set
to feature Scarlet Witch as a prominent player
and will apparently tie into the Loki series
as well.
So, while Avengers: Endgame may be the current
top dog in the MCU, it's far from the only
exciting Marvel property that will call Disney+
its new streaming home.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.